[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les pieds sur
terre le magazine qui explore l'écologie
sous toutes ses
[Musique]
formes
dans ce numéro direction le Jura à la
découverte de citadins qui ont choisi le
retour à la
terre cadre dans l'industrie femme de
ménage banquier ou encore r soignant un
beau jour ils ont décidé de changer de
vie de quitter la ville et les
particules fines pour devenir
agriculteur et chaque année ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux en France à
franchir le cap on les appelle les
néoruraux et c'est une tendance forte
alors peut-on tout quitter pour devenir
paysan comment réussir sa reconversion
les pieds sur terre vous répondre
[Musique]
suivez-moi Patrice béget a opéré un
changement de vie radical il y a 5 ans
il en a eu assez de la grisaille
citadine et du rythme de vie effrainé
avec sa femme ils ont décidé de tout
plaquer pour produire du vin dans sa
région natale le dou bonjour Patrice
bonjour on est en plein milieu de de vos
vignes là oui à mé j'ai la moitié de mes
vignes ici depuis 2009 il s'est installé
dans ce petit village de met où il
exploite 4 hectares de vign avant cela
il était ingénieur en informatique à
Bruxelles Paris puis
Montpellier j'arrivais pas à me lever le
matin malgré que j'ai des supers
collègues des super patrons j'étais très
bien payé je euh mon travail se passait
très très bien mais j'étais voilà je
trouvais aucun sens en dans ce que je
faisais et j'avais besoin d'être dans la
nature dans le verre voilà et là le
verre je l'ai
trouvé mais avant de se lancer et de
venir s'installer ici Patrice a suivi
une formation à la viticulture et à
l'eunologie alors comment ça se passe
alors bah déjà il te faut quelques armes
pour
travailler il a tout appris il cultive
désormais ses vignes produit son vin et
le
vent qu'est-ce que vous êtes venu
chercher en faisant du vin et en vous
occupant de vos vignes alors au départ
j'avais une version un peu romantique du
métier et je voulais être surtout libre
et je me rends compte qu'en fait je suis
pas si libre que ça dans mon métier et
pas aussi libre que j'aurais imaginé
c'est qu' toujours quand même pas mal de
contraintes là comment une certaine
pression aussi de
vente une partie administrative à faire
régulièrement qui était pas ce que
j'avais forcément rêvé mais par contre
de faire mon vin de faire mes vignes
c'était mon rêve et j'ai ce que je
voulais peu importe l'effort physique et
le mal de dos Patrice V sa passion le
matin il n'a plus l'impression d'aller
travailler avec sa terre on peut même
par d'une histoire
[Musique]
d'amour 4 hectares de vign 11000
bouteilles produites par an et comme si
le défi de la reconversion ne suffisait
pas Patrice a choisi l'agriculture
biologique comme de nombreux
néoruraux mais il est même allé plus
loin puisqu'il pratique la biodynamie
soit un refus total de tout pesticide ou
engrais chimique Patrice Swan sville par
des tisanes ou des coctions 100 %
naturell qu'est-ce que vous êtes en
train de préparer là alors là c'est de
l'eau de
pluie dans un espèce de mélangeur qui va
brasser ça l'eau pendant une heure et
puis moi je lui rajoute donc cette
préparation mais c'est en quantité c'est
100 g par hectare c'est la Bousse Bousse
de vache qui a passé qui a passé 6 mois
dans une corne de vache enterrée et qui
fait un engrais voilà tiens tu peux
toucher c'est c'est la Bousse de vache
qui sent le sousbois qui a pas vraiment
l'odeur de merde et c'est ce qui va
aider ma vigne à être équilibré et et
dynamique en fait c'est là au printemps
là c'est vraiment un petit coup de pouce
voilà pour
démarrer une fois le mélange prêt il
faut encore le répendre sur les hectares
de
[Musique]
vignes mais au-delà d'un nouveau métier
c'est une nouvelle vie pour Patrice et
sa famille il peut consacrer du temps à
ses deux enfants Basti
et jeonne du miel c'est du miel que tu
veux c'est
ça une nouvelle vie avec sa femme
anglaise diplômée de Cambridge qui a
renoncé à une carrière professionnelle
prometteuse pour venir dans le
jur aujourd'hui le RSA mais bientôt cela
ne sera plus
nécessaire c'est c'est sûr ça na pas é
évident de quitter de postes bien payé
en ville et puis maintenant on vit dans
mon rau fraîche depuis quelques temps
mais on a un joli cadre de vie notre
fils va à l'école à 50 m on y va à pied
on voulait pas on voulait pas avoir
d'enfants dans une dans une grande ville
ça on c'était dit CIT pas possible quoi
et financièrement et enfin humainement
on sentit pas d'élever des enfants au
milieu des des voitures quoi un choix de
vie assumé qui leur laisse peu de répis
et c'est vrai que c'est dur quoi c'est
c'est on narrête pas on narrête pas quoi
on narrête jamais donc ben de concilier
travail et VI familial pourtant on est
tout est localisé ici mais mais rien que
on est deux on a que deux enfants mais
le soir on est on a couru toute la
journée s'écroule on est
ex sauf que avant de s'écrouler il faut
créer quand même quelques mail il faut
régler quelques papierers c'est ça
surtout c'est que même le soir on
travaille encore d'une certaine
façon c'est pas pareil on est salarié
les qure premières années Patrice n'a
pas pris un seul jour de
repos alors si vous Patrice fait 5 ans
que vous avez changé de vie une
reconversion dans l'agriculture ça se
prépare direction le centre de formation
professionnelle et de promotion agricole
de montmorau juste à côté de Lon leniier
où chaque année ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à franchir le cap on y
va mais on ne s'improvise pas
agriculteur d'ailleurs pour recevoir les
aides à l'installation il faut obtenir
un diplôme délivré
ici Antoine lui aussi veut changer de
vie il veut devenir pays en boulanger il
y a un an à peine il était cadre dans
l'industrie automobile bon alors Antoine
c'est pas trop dur de reprendre les
cours bah c'est pas facile il y a un
rythme qu'on a plus l'esprit j'ai
l'impression que l'esprit ne fonctionne
plus comme avant ou avant on était
scolaire on était dans un rythme
scolaire là j'ai avec la coupure de
l'industrie parce qu'avant vous étiez
alors avant avant j'étais dans
l'automobile chez PSA pendant 15 ans bon
ben voilà c'est un nouveau projet qui se
qui se
dessine est très enthousiasm mais mais
plein d'inconnus quoi vous allez nous
raconter tout ça après parce que je
crois que on nous attend sur
leson on y
aller ce matin cours théorique pour
Antoine sur les rotations des cultures
et ses
techniques pour lutter contre les advtis
c'est ça c'est suffisant c'est une
première étape qui est très très
importante on va revenir un tout petit
peu des notions assez fondamentales on a
déjà parlé un peu il me semble mais
c'est un petit peu
[Musique]
duré dans sa classe ils sont nombreux
comme Antoine à opérer une reconversion
professionnelle plus qu'une tendance
c'est devenu la norme cette his quelle
est la proportion exacte de reconvertis
qui suivent votre
formation aujourd'hui on a allez si on a
on a bien 80 % de gens qui se
reconvertissent qui viennent pas du
monde agricole et le nombre a bien
augmenté depuis la crise franchement ah
oui c'est la crise de c'est quoi sur les
quatre dernières années où on voit qu'il
y a de plus en plus de reconvertis ouais
je crois que ça ça a énormément joué
pour certains c'est peut-être pas un
vrai choix parce que ils sont sur le
carreau quoi faire d'autre pour d'autres
c'est un vrai choix si parce que il y en
a quand même plein dans le groupe ici
tous les ans il y a plein de gens qui
refusent cette société actuelle et qui
et qui veulent revenir à des vraies
valeurs que que représente l'agriculture
qu'ils défendent quoi et souvent une
agriculture bio souvent une agriculture
avec des produits de qualité avec la
liaison avec le consommateur c'est
vraiment ça qui est recherché par un bon
nombre de gens quand même est-ce qu'il y
a des échecs
oui comme partout il y a des échecs il y
a des gens il y a des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à s'installer parce que
c'est difficile de trouver du foncier
euh vous savez les agriculteurs en place
il font pas forcément beaucoup de place
à ces à ces à ces nouveaux arrivés qui
qui veulent vivre d'un métier qui est
très différent en fait de par les
pratiques de par la relation qu'ils ont
à au consommateur est-ce qu'il vous
arrive parfois de dissuader les
audacieux ça nous arrive oui lorsque le
lorsque le projet est complètement
utopique c'est notre devoir quand même
de dire attention on peut pas non plus
faire n'importe
[Musique]
quoi
là du coup il y a un risque s' gèle
encore ça peut tout oui le risque au
niveau du gel là ça va être au niveau du
gel des
épillets paysan boulanger un métier
laborieux et complet il faut cultiver
ses céréales faire sa farine pétrir sa
pâte cuire son pain et le
vendre mais son projet Antoine père de C
enfant l'a beaucoup
pensé on apprend à monter son projet à
avoir une viabilité économique de notre
projet et je pense que c'est intéressant
de se poser la question est-ce que ce
que j'ai en tête de mon métier est-ce
que ça peut se réaliser concrètement et
nourrir une famille qu'est-ce que vous
redoutez le plus dans votre future
nouvelle vie je sais que ce sera un
métier difficile he je me vois pas la
face non plus c'est c'est d'autres
contraintes que l'industri mais il y en
a aussi j'en suis conscient mais
je c'est c'est aussi ce que je cherche à
travers ce projet
c'est ne pas s'installer dans un dans
dans le confort Parce que je pense que
c'est très éducateur pour les enfants
aussi pour la famille moi c'est aussi un
projet familial donc c'est aussi des
valeurs que je veux transmettre à mes
enfants le goût de l'effort la volonté
de d'entreprendre de réussir quelque
chose alors Antoine quand est-ce qu'on
pourra espérer goûter votre pain
j'espère faire du pain d'ici 2 ans à peu
près bah Antoine en tout cas on vous
souhaite bonne chance et puis beaucoup
de succès et ben je vous
remercie la reconversion d'Antoine est
bien entamée mais il lui faut encore
terminer sa formation avant de semer les
premières graines et espérer dans la
foulée récolter son
blé changer de vie devenir agriculteur
c'est possible à condition de s être
préparé comme Antoine et Patrice d'avoir
le soutien de ses proches et un peu de
ressources financières car l'aventure
est longue avant de pouvoir vivre de ces
cultures d'ailleurs certains mettent la
clé sous la porte dans les deux trois
premières années mais c'est bon à savoir
désormais toutes les chambres
d'agriculture ont des dispositifs
d'accompagnement et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi et
à très bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de
ce rendez-vous dédié à l'environnement
d'ici là gardez la tête sur les épaules
et les pieds sur terre
Ciao
the sun is
shining any